صيد ثمين وقع تحت ايدي القراء وهو اقتناء
الكتب الذين استقبلوا بتفاعل ملموس اكبر
مكتبه عائمه في العالم وتدعى لجثهوب وذلك
بعد رسولها في ميناء غرب بورسعيد شمال
شرقي مصر وعلمتها اكثر من 5000 كتاب تتيح
لوجو هوب للزوار الابحار بين مجموعه
مختاره من الكتب في مختلف المجالات مثل
العلوم والرياضه والفنون والطب والروايات
باللغه العربيه والانجليزيه
كبيره جدا
يمكن ان نقول اننا اكبر مكتبه عائمه في
العالم لدينا طاقم مكون بالكامل من
متطوعين 330 فردا من اكثر من 60 دوله
مختلفه ياتون وقتهم هنا على متن السفينه
وقع اختيار السفينه على بورسعيد لتكون الى
وجهاتها في العام الجديد وستبقى هناك حتى
الثالث والعشرين من الشهر الحالي انا شايف
ان في تجديد في المكان وشايفه ان في زياده
في الكتب يعني حاجات اكثر من المره اللي
فاتت بكتير افيد اا حاجات كتب من جميع
انحاء العالم
بلغات مختلفه من جميع دول العالم ال- اا
ال- الاستفاده بقى من المركب دي ان ايه ان
هي من سن ثلاث سنين طفل لغايه 60 سنه
مستفيدين من ال همم من المركب
منظمه تجيب اي شيبس الالمانيه غير الربحيه
السفينه اللوجوس هوب وتهدفه الى نشر
المعرفه والامل في كل ميناء تزوره
وتواصل لوكس هوب عملها الى جانبي سفينتين
اخرىين فقد زارت تلك السفن اكثر من 150
دوله ومنطقه ومنذ عام
1970 واستقبل 49 مليون شخص على متنها
بحاسب بيان للمنظمه هي ليست سفينه ومعرضا
للكتاب فحسب وفقط رقمها ومتطوعها بل تمثل
رؤيه تصنع فرقا وتساهم في تطور الانسان
وتقدم المعرفه من خلال الكتب المعروضه